in der Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
es geht um Abschreckung Wirksamkeit und
Einsatzfähigkeit eine Zeitenwende
willkommen bei sicherheitshalber dem
Podcast zur Sicherheitspolitik am
Mikrofon wie immer Thomas Wiegold von
Augen geradeaus
von der Universität der Bundeswehr in
München und Carlo Mars oder ebenfalls
von Universität der Bundeswehr in
München
[Musik]
kurz für die Laufpublikum die neuen wer
das noch nicht so kennt wer wir sind und
für die Fernsehzuschauer
mein Name ist Thomas Wiegold ich
schreibe einen Block das heißt Augen
geradeaus zur verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitspolitik seit einer guten
Dekade und befasse mich als Journalist
mit dem Thema seit ein paar Jahrzehnten
fantastisch mein Name ist Ulrike Franke
ich arbeite bei einem europäischen Think
Tank aktuell in Paris der europame
relations und arbeitet so europäischer
und deutscher
sicherheitsverteilungspolitik und ganz
viele so neu Technologien Drohnen und
sowas
mein Name ist Frank sauer ich arbeite
wie gesagt an der Universität der
Bundeswehr in München und beschäftige
mich mit internationaler Sicherheit bin
von Haus aus Politikwissenschaftler und
habe Schwerpunkte auch im Bereich neue
Technologien und vor allem auch
Nuklearwaffen
calomasala Professor für internationale
Politik an der Universität der
Bundeswehr in München
Schwerpunkt Arbeitsgebiete alles rund
ums töten
wir wollen reden über
ja es hat mit der Ukraine zu tun wir
reden über die Ukraine wir reden aber
nicht über den aktuellen Kriegsverlauf
wir reden auch nicht darüber was
geschehen muss damit dieser Krieg zu
Ende geht was wir alle ja hoffen dass
das nicht so erfahren in der Zukunft
liegt sondern wir reden darüber
wie es dann eigentlich weitergeht also
wir haben es genannt wenn die Waffen
endlich Schweigen Wege zu einem stabilen
Frieden in Europa
denn das die Kampfhandlungen enden dann
geht das richtig los mit den
Schwierigkeiten
Carlo
kommst Du kurz rein ins Thema ja ich
komme ganz kurz rein und mach mal was
Günter Grass und weites Feld genannt hat
wir reden wir werden nicht darüber reden
sozusagen wie ein möglicher Frieden in
der Ukraine aussehen könnte das ist
nicht das Thema sondern das Thema ist
sozusagen was alles darum herum
organisiert werden muss mit der Ukraine
um zu einer Art Sicherheit und
Stabilität in Europa nachdem die Waffen
schweigen kommt zu kommen und letzten
Endes kann man das nur auf der Basis von
13 Szenarien die gar nicht skizziert
werden sollen sondern nur genannt werden
sollen dieser Krieger drei aus mögliche
Ausgänge die Ukraine gewinnt die Russen
gewinnen oder die Situation wie sie
jetzt ist zieht sich noch für Jahre
hinweg der berühmte eingefrorene
Konflikte der berühmte frozen Konflikt
genau egal wie sozusagen welches
Szenario letzten Endes sich realisiert
bestehende ganze Reihe von Aufgaben über
die wir diskutieren wollen die letzten
Endes jetzt schon angepackt werden
müssen angegangen werden müssen
das eine ist natürlich diese
Friedensverhandlungen müssen jetzt schon
vorbereitet werden obwohl die Zeit für
Friedensverhandlungen noch nicht da ist
müssen sie jetzt schon vorbereitet
werden und Sie müssen sozusagen
vorbereitet werden einmal mit Blick auf
die Frage Russland und Ukraine und
einmal mit Blick auf die Frage wie
entfaltet sich dann wie entwickelt sich
an die europäische sicherheitsordnung
bzw die transatlantische Ordnung mit
Blick auf Sicherheit in Europa
man kann davon ausgehen dass die
Verhandlungen wenn also wenn es zu einem
Waffenstillstand kommt wenn es zu
Verhandlungen zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine kommt dass das die schwierigsten
aber auch die längsten Verhandlungen
werden die wir seit Jahrzehnten gesehen
haben bei einem zwischenstaatlichen
Krieg oder auch bei Bürgerkriegen also
die älteren hier im Publikum du auf
jeden Fall noch ein paar andere die
werden nicht dass irgendjemand älter es
muss ganz offen sagen Thomas
werden sich daran erinnern dass die
Verhandlungen zwischen den USA und
vietnamen sich elendig lange hingezogen
also der Nordvietnamesen ich glaube
sozusagen das wird das toppen was wir an
verhandlungslänge kennen aber die müssen
halt jetzt schon vorbereitet werden und
während Verhandlungen laufen muss halt
europäische Sicherheit neu organisiert
werden und da
und da will ich nur ganz kurz so ein
paar Punkte machen die man dabei
berücksichtigen muss also einmal
natürlich dieser Klassiker darüber reden
was ich laufe wie ist das Verhältnis EU
NATO wer übernimmt was wie macht man was
zusammen wie ist das wie ist die Frage
Ukraine in EU und NATO das sind alles
wichtige Aspekte wie ist die Sicherheit
der Ukraine zu garantieren ist auch ein
wichtiger Aspekt und dann kommt
eigentlich sozusagen möglicherweise der
größte Körper und das sind die
Präsidentschaftswahlen in den USA wie
ist das Ganze zu organisieren sollte in
den USA so eine Trump ähnliche Figur
oder Trump selber die Wahlen gewinnen
aber auch wenn die Demokraten die Wahlen
gewinnen man schaut in die Nation
Security strategy da ist relativ klar
abzusehen dass die eigentlich nicht so
richtig Lust haben hier so massiv
präsent zu sein und gerne sozusagen ihre
Präsenz hier reduzieren würde was
wiederum die Frage stellt wie ersetzen
wir die amerikanische Präsenz mit Blick
auf eine mögliche Abschreckung Russland
auf mögliche Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine also abschließen Günter Gras
ein weiteres Feld und über das
Diskutieren jetzt wer redet denn
eigentlich mit wem man hat ja den
Eindruck dass Russland vor allem der
Meinung ist mit der Ukraine muss man gar
nicht reden sondern mit den Europäern
eigentlich auch nicht ja mit der
Amerikaner nur mit den mit den USA weil
alle anderen sind nicht
fraktionsfähig ich glaube letzten Endes
was du dazu hinkommen jetzt gehe ich mal
wieder zurück als der zweite Golfkrieg
zu Ende war haben wir die
Amerikanerin das war 1991 haben die
Amerikaner damals mit der Sowjetunion
die noch existierte den Madrid auf
Friedensprozess gemacht und dieser
Madrider Friedensprozess war letzten
Endes eine Ansammlung von kleinen
verhandlungsforen
wo die USA und die Sowjetunion drüber
saßen und das ganze moderiert haben und
ich glaube so wird das auch laufen es
gibt Aspekte da kommen die Russen nicht
umhin sozusagen mit den Ukrainern direkt
zu verhandeln unter Anleitung von
einigen und ich glaube diese
Verhandlungen muss man sehr sehr
kleinteilig machen also nicht das große
Paket sondern sehr sehr kleinteilig oder
geht dann um die Frage Status Don Bass
Status und Grimm andere Fragen
Rüstungskontrolle vielleicht und ich
glaube das ganze wird präsentiert werden
ähm und das glaube ich die einzige
Möglichkeit die ich sehe von den USA und
den Chinesen also wird große Konferenz
werden die aber kleinteilig organisiert
ist ich habe eine andere parallele ist
nicht von mir sondern habe ich gestern
in einem foreigner Ferse Artikel gelesen
und die sprachen darüber dass man sich
vielleicht ein Beispiel nehmen kann an
den 2 + 4 Verhandlungen was ich ganz
spannend fand die Logik also das 2 + 4
die beiden Deutschland die damals
verhandelt haben und eben die ähm die
die vier ja Siegermächte und die haben
die parallel gemacht wir brauchen
eigentlich zwei plus vier Verhandlung
zwei
Ukraine und Russland die eben über den
Frieden verhandeln möglich so wie
schweigen die Waffen entmaliten
militarisierte Zonen was weiß ich und
dann die vier das in dem Fall nicht viel
sind aber eben quasi so die die
übergeordneten wie soll man das nennen
die unterstützenden Mächte also sprich
die Nato-Partner wobei vielleicht nicht
unbedingt alle die Amerikaner und ja
dann irgendwie halt auch mit Russland
und ohne Ukraine die quasi die die
Sicherheitsarchitektur auf die das
kommen soll verhandeln sollten
interessante Parallele das einzige der
einzige Unterschied für mich ist das in
diesem vier ähm Element dann eben auch
irgendwie Russland und die Ukraine mit
dabei sein können weil wir können ja
nicht über der Kopf eine wie auch immer
geartete europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur verhandeln aber
ich glaube sozusagen bei den Fragen die
es in der Ukraine zu fahren gibt
brauchst du halt ähm externe starten mit
an Bord
also die zwei alleine verhandeln nicht
über den Frieden sondern sozusagen da
müssen die Amerikaner oder die Chinesen
oder die Europäer je nachdem um was es
geht einfach mit einsteigen also Moment
ich verstehe bei dieser ganz ganz sagen
die die Überlegung ist ja bei all diesen
Mustern da verhandeln welche die haben
aber jeder sozusagen noch den großen
Bruder den dem Patenonkel wie auch immer
im Hintergrund das funktioniert bei
dieser Konstruktion mit der Vorstellung
im Westen sind die USA der
größte Bär im Raum es funktioniert aber
nicht auf russischer Seite wieso ja wer
denn die Chinesen du musst du musst ja
sozusagen du brauchst ja nicht Mächte
den du vertraust sondern die du
akzeptierst und in dem Moment in dem die
Waffen schweigen und in dem Moment in
dem sich beide Seiten gedrängt oder
freiwillig auch in den
Verhandlungsprozess begeben werden die
Russen auch die Chinesen akzeptieren die
Russen akzeptieren ja jetzt nur nicht
sozusagen das chinesische drängen auf
irgendwelche Veränderungen in diesem
aktuellen Krieger in dem Moment wo
verhandelt wird brauchen die Russen auch
irgendjemanden der hinter ihnen steht
der genug Gewicht hat um gegebenenfalls
mit den USA direkt zu verhandeln
also mir ist es eigentlich ein bisschen
zu spekulativ
im Prinzip Schema dass wir heute
behandeln spekulativ das stimmt das
stimmt aber um die Diskussion mal zu
strukturieren würde ich sagen es gibt ja
im Prinzip zwei Diskussionsstränge die
für uns relevant sind das eine ist die
europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur also
im weitesten Sinne die Frage wie
organisieren wir Sicherheit nicht mehr
mit sondern gegen vor und um Russland
herum das ist sozusagen der eine Punkt
und die die der zweite Teil der
Diskussion sind die konkreten Fragen die
sich für die Ukraine Stellen die für uns
natürlich in Relevanz haben nämlich die
Frage wie ist es mit EU-Mitgliedschaft
wie es mit NATO Mitgliedschaft wie es
mit anderen Sicherheitsgarantien sind es
dann Garantien sind Zusagen sind es ja
also was ist das ähm und wenn man
vielleicht sozusagen mal auf diese auf
die höhere Ebene erstmal gehen wollte
und wir fangen mal damit an und fragen
uns wie ist Sicherheit in Europa wenn
irgendwann die Waffen schweigen
dann würde ich mal die steile These
Wagen das wenn gleich Mann und das habe
ich auch in vielen Folgen schon immer
wieder betont und dann gleich mal
vorsichtig sein muss mit den Blaupausen
aus dem Kalten Krieg aber wenn man nach
einer Blaupause suchen wollte oder nach
einem Begriff
der den Umgang mit Russland in den
nächsten Jahren und Jahrzehnten
kennzeichnet dann würde ich sagen
Containment ja und ich unter uns ist es
vielleicht jetzt nicht sonderlich
strittig aber wenn man zum Beispiel mal
sich mit Leuten in Deutschland aus der
Industrie unterhält die haben da eine
ganz andere Perspektive drauf oder gibt
es definitiv immer noch eine sehr stark
naja gut das kann ja nicht mehr ewig
gehen und dann irgendwann kommen wir
auch wieder so zu normalen Austausch und
wer weiß vielleicht fließt auch wieder
das Gas und ähm ich will auch später
noch hoffentlich wenn man dazu kommen
ein bisschen das alles ein bisschen
einschränken aber jetzt erstmal würde
ich einen klare Kante fahren wollen und
sagen die grundlegende Logik die wir
anders Verhältnis Europas zu Russland
herantragen sollten ist eine der
Eindämmung um zu verhindern dass noch
mal Aggression in dieser Form
stattfinden kann und das hat
Implikationen für uns wie wir unsere
Sicherheit organisieren wie wir uns
aufstellen und das hat natürlich
insbesondere für die Ukraine aber
vielleicht für Länder wie Georgien
molder und so weiter massive
Konsequenzen mit Blick darauf wie die
mit Sicherheit organisieren also ja im
Prinzip meine These an dieser Stelle ist
Containment ist eigentlich das was wir
machen solange ist Herrn Putin gibt aber
ich glaube sogar darüber hinausgehen
solange es diesen
putinismus genannt so diese Mischung aus
aus Chauvinismus Nationalismus mit fast
faschistoiden Tendenzen inzwischen in
diesem Land die einfach das ist uns
jetzt vor Augen geführt worden dazu
führen dass Russland ein massiver
unsicherheitsaktor in dieser Region ist
und ich glaube das ist für uns eine
drastische Umstellung auf dem Kopf und
die Spitze das ganze jetzt mal zu und
sage wer weiß vielleicht kriegen wir
demnächst tatsächlich wenn sich das
alles so manifestiert mit Belus und
dieser Idee das Russland da äh irgendwie
Nuklearwaffen diskutiert z.B wieder in
der Diskussion ob wir zusätzlich nur
klar Waffen in wasserober vielleicht in
Deutschland stationieren oder
Mittelstrecken
ja also so nach dem Motto 80er ich hör
dir trapsen ja haben wir noch mal gehabt
also solche Sachen schließe ich
zumindest nicht aus kann ich meinem ganz
kurz weil ich die Frage interessant
finde Natur Russland Grundakte haben wir
immer wieder erwähnt wo drinsteht die
NATO wird auf dem Gebiet des ehemaligen
Ostblocks keine Atomwaffen mehr
ist die Tod
die Amis die Deutschen sind doof dass
sie dran festhalten die wird glaube ich
offiziell nie aufgekündigt werden also
den Schritt wird die NATO nicht machen
ja sie wird diese Grundakte nicht
sozusagen in die Tonne werfen aber du
siehst ja jetzt die Diskussion also du
hast die Diskussion über nukleare Teil
aber in Polen
du hast noch immer die Diskussion ob
dieses vorgeschobene brigadeelement der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht zu
einer festen Brigade in Litauen werden
soll also die Diskussion läuft darauf
hin dass bei ganz ganz vielen Maßnahmen
die gerade diskutiert werden wir wissen
alle nicht wie sie entschieden werden
aber natürlich die nato-grundakte
verletzt wird so die ist tot das ist ein
totes Papier aber ich glaube man kündigt
es nicht auf weil man diesen Schritt
sozusagen nicht gehen will der
Russischen Föderation Propaganda
Argument zu geben die NATO geht auf
einen neuen Kalten Krieg hin weil diese
vertragliche Grundlage wird jetzt auch
gekündigt
sie nicht auf offiziell oder man bricht
sie nicht weil mir erscheint es ja
schlecht da wenn man sie quasi bricht
also quasi nicht an die Regeln hätten
sie nicht aufkündigt also dann ich sag
mal so die Diskussion läuft in die
Richtung brechen ja also es ist halt die
Nuklein das ist sozusagen die Brigade
die jetzt dann fest nicht als
vorgeschobenes Element sondern fest ja
dann kommt die die sagen das sind ja
eine substanziellen Kampftruppen doch
darauf hat man sich ja geeinigt 5000
deutsche Brigade mit dreieinhalb oder so
die muss dann nicht so schlimm aber du
weißt was ich meine es ist eine
permanente Stationierung ja klar im in
einem osteuropäischen Mitgliedstaat
sagen wir mal die Atomwaffen von Büchel
nach emmerie
irgendwo nach Polen gehen werden sondern
das sozusagen ein kleines Paket von
neuen in Polen ankommen wird
okay aber hier habe ich eine Frage weil
wir reden jetzt momentan noch darüber
wie organisieren wir NATO Stationierung
auf NATO Territorium aber was ist denn
eigentlich mit Truppen in der Ukraine
weil nie ja da kommt jetzt genau mein
Fragezeichen denn
wenn dieser Krieg jetzt mal endet können
wir doch eigentlich bevorzuge zu sagen
wenn die Kampfhandlung malen wenn die
Kampfhandlungen enden wird es doch
ziemlich sicher also der Konflikt endet
ja nicht ne das ist ja nicht politische
Konflikt der politische Konflikt endet
ja nicht das heißt die Ukraine braucht
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Sicherheitsgarantien ich würde die
argumentieren die erste und wichtigste
Sicherheitsgarantie für die Ukraine ist
es ukrainische Militär sehr gut
auszustatten vor allen Dingen auch mit
die Geschichten aber es gibt ja noch ein
anderes Element und das ist die frage
werden wir und wir ist jetzt genau die
Frage letztendlich Truppen in die
Ukraine schicken wird es da eine
UN-Mission geben un super spannend weil
Russland ist ja bekannterweise im Moment
Sicherheitsrat geht das dann eigentlich
machen wir das über die über die
Generalversammlung der enden
friedensbewahrende Truppen peacekeeping
sowas Waffenstillstand sichern und
Kontaktlinsen
auf irgendwas wird man sich ja einigen
wird das nur un-gruppe wird das eine
nato-geschichte da würde ich schon
direkt dazu sagen wahrscheinlich nicht
also wird wahrscheinlich Russland dich
dazu kommt jetzt endlich die Stunde der
OSZE die ja komplett irgendwie
verschwunden ist in den letzten Monaten
oder
oder bauen wir was neues und ähm es habe
ich auch schon gelesen es gibt irgendwie
eine neuen noch eine neue Organisation
die sich da drauf setzen also ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass wir eine EU
hast du gar nicht
ja ich wundere mich auch die ganze Zeit
ja
nicht sicher ob du noch einen Job hast
aber ich meine jetzt sind wir ja schon
sozusagen sehr viel näher dran an der
Debatte sagen wie es mit der Ukraine im
konkreten weitergeht und da sind wir
auch wieder bei Toten Papieren ja
Stichwort Budapester also Budapester
von 1994 in der ja also sozusagen eine
Deklaration die
in deren Rahmen unter anderem eben die
Ukraine die noch verbleibenden
sowjetischen Nuklearwaffen
abgegeben hat an Russland und dafür hat
sie naja und da haben wir schon was hat
sie eigentlich bekommen
und ja also sieht man ja wie das für die
Ukraine gelaufen ist nicht so gut würde
ich mal sagen und also letzten Endes
glaube ich das ja der einzige Weg ähm
die Sicherheit der Ukraine zu
garantieren ich glaube nicht dass die
Ukraine NATO Mitglied werden wird Punkt
so jetzt kommen jetzt kommen Punkt
machen wir weiter und der einzige Weg
ist leider Gottes muss ich das sagen ist
diese Rasmussen Idee also zu sagen die
Ukraine braucht im Prinzip das
israelische Modell sie braucht nukleare
Sicherheitsgarantien seitens der
Vereinigten Staaten und das sind die
einzigen sozusagen die das geben können
so dass es glaubwürdig ist gegenüber den
Russen und sie muss ein Militär haben
dass das modernste Militär in dieser
Region ist und zwar massiv ausgerüstet
und aufgerüstet so dass auf der
konventionellen Ebene in der Lage ist
russische drucken abzuschrecken ja also
alles andere wirklich funktionieren
deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht diese
ganze Geschichte die hier in Deutschland
ist wenn man dann immer sagt ja die
Deutschen werden auch dabei sind
Sicherheitsgarantien zu geben womit denn
mit was denn ja so also es geht nur in
der Kombination das ukrainische Militär
muss das modernste in dieser Region
werden sie muss so gut ausgerüstet
werden egal mit was das ist eine
abschreckende Wirkung auf die
konventionellen Streitkräfte der
Russischen Föderation hat und
gleichzeitig muss es ist ein Vertrag
geben mit dem Vereinigten Staaten über
nukleare Sicherheitsgarantie da können
die Franzosen die Briten auch gerne
dabei sein das hilft nur nichts weil die
Franzosen haben eine rein Nation
alle zeigen auch
nationale nuklear Strategie deswegen
also es können nur die USA machen Punkt
zum Ausrüstung weil wir das ganz wichtig
ist wir sind uns glaube ich jetzt hier
in der Runde relativ einig dass das
ukrainische Militär sehr gut ausgerüstet
werden er muss auch für die Zeit danach
und ich betone diesen Punkt nur so weil
mich das immer so ärgert jetzt in der
Diskussion um Waffenlieferung habe ich
immer den Eindruck dass Du getan wird ja
aber jetzt in dieser aktuellen
Kampfsituation brauchen die das ja nicht
oder wir wollen ihn jetzt in der
aktuellen Kampfsituation XY nicht geben
weil dann machen Sie am Ende noch
s genau
aber was ich mir immer denke und das ist
jetzt zum Beispiel Stichwort zu den
Kampfflugzeugen ist doch wir müssen doch
das ukrainische Militär langfristig
ausrüsten insofern spricht ja überhaupt
nichts dagegen jetzt z.B Kampfpiloten zu
trainieren mindestens eben für die Zeit
danach dann kann man immer noch drüber
nachdenken wann man das liefert und ob
das jetzt für die aktuelle was machen
Piloten aus das weiß ich jetzt auch
nicht da gab es so eine etwas
merkwürdige Aussage aber egal aber das
war einfach nur ein Punkt ich finde es
einfach wichtig dass wenn über
Waffenlieferung diskutiert wird dass
vielen Leuten scheinbar nicht klar zu
sein scheint dass es eben hinausgeht
über jetzt die aktuellen Kampfhandlungen
und ja auch die Ausrüstung der Ukraine
danach ist weil das finde ich auch die
wichtigsten ich habe das vorhin nur so
ein geworfen aber vielleicht sollte ich
das noch mal ganz klar sagen wenn die
Waffen schweigen wird aller Voraussicht
nach der politische Konflikt nicht
gelöst sein das heißt es wird weiterhin
ein in irgendeiner Weise putinisches
Russland geben was der Ukraine
mehr oder weniger in so vielen Worten
und setzen das Existenzrecht abspricht
also deswegen greift eben die Logik zu
sagen ah die sind ja angegriffen na gut
dann geben wir Ihnen jetzt das nötigsten
damit sie sich verteidigen können und
wenn dann endlich Frieden ist ist
Frieden greift viel zu kurz weil wir
eben schon sozusagen diesen politischen
Konflikt mal in Gänze bedenken müssen
und weil du das jetzt so rein geworfen
hast dieses Rassismus ein Papier muss
man vielleicht mal sagen was es
überhaupt ist also anders ehemaliger
Natur Generalsekretär muss man auch ganz
klar sagen der Mann ist einfach privat
Mann ja also eine Beratungsfirma hat so
eine beratungsbude genau und ähm
der hat diesen Kief Security compact
ja mal aufgeschrieben was im Prinzip
eine so eine Art Kochrezept sein könnte
für eben eine nachkriegsukraine und den
wesentlichen Punkt hast du schon gesagt
also man muss sie halt irgendwie oder
haben wir gesagt und und hat Rike jetzt
auch noch mal drauf hingewiesen wir
brauchen natürlich Ausrüstung Training
Ausbildung und Waffen um die Ukraine
insgesamt zu so einer Art Igel zu machen
ja mit vielen vielen Stacheln wo keiner
hingehen will und noch mal rein beißen
und andere Elemente die auch zu diesem
Tief Security compact gehören werden
eben Snapback Sanktionen also dass man
im Prinzip vor her schon ein Katalog
aufschreiben seit Russland pass auf noch
mal irgendwie noch so ein Ding
Augenringen quasi ja also da beißt sich
aber und das ist das das ist eines
genau das ist nämlich eines der Probleme
in diesem Papier weil letzten Endes geht
es ja dann davon aus dass in dem Moment
in dem es irgendeine Lösung gibt die
Sanktion weg sind das kannst aber nicht
machen wenn du Containment betreibst
weil du musst die Sanktionen z.B im
Hochtechnologie Bereich aufrecht
erhalten damit die russische
zumindestens das her sich nicht
regenerieren kann ja und sozusagen die
Waffenproduktion weitermachen kann und
dabei ist es sich ein bisschen
erinnert mich daran das heißt
warum so alt ist doch keiner sowas
jedenfall
klar geworden ist wir haben ja unser
sanktionspulver aufgebraucht würde ich
sagen wir können ja nicht noch mehr also
doch wir können noch mehr Sanktionen
machen aber relevant ist es dass das
Russland irgendwie noch mal naja
gaspombank Swift Ausschluss wenn ich
denken eben auch
also quasi Sanktionen die direkt
automatisch
greifen wenn Russland XY macht also zum
Beispiel noch mal einen Angriff macht da
muss ja noch irgendwas zum sanktionieren
haben und ich finde auch dass setzt dann
voraus dass im Moment eines wie auch
immer gearteten Friedensschlusses oder
Ende der Kampfhandlung irgendwas auch
wieder zurückgenommen wird und das wird
deswegen habe ich ja gesagt
nämlich zu sagen so
eingefroren Kampfhandlung beendet und
wir sorgen dafür dass Russland nicht
mehr hochkommt
richtig dann sind wir wirklich bei 1918
ja weit von kopieren hier die Leute
unterschrieben maximal 100.000 Mann in
der Reichswehr keine Panzer keine
U-Boote ich weiß nicht was noch nicht
aber weißt du was der Unterschied ist
Deutschland wurde dann faschistisch
Russland ist schon faschistisch macht
das besser nee aber der Punkt ist
sozusagen so lange und da kommt der
Frankreich solange dieser putinismus im
Sinne von sozusagen näher imperiale
Agenda existiert kannst du nicht die
Sanktionen
in den Bereichen zurücknehmen die ist
der Russischen Föderation erlaubt
sozusagen ihre Waffenproduktion wieder
auf einem moderneren Stand zu bringen
weil dann brauchen die
NATO gesagt 3 bis 5 Jahre dann
regeneriert sie verstehen
Professor also der hat ja nicht
sozusagen kausal zum Faschismus in oder
zum Nationalsozialismus in Deutschland
geführt das ist ja so einer der Mythen
zu sagen die Deutschland nur die Nazis
gewählt weil es dem Vertrag gehabt
aber sozusagen ursächlich waren andere
Faktoren
Vertrag und wie gesagt
aber nee ich wollte nur sagen
kann
[Gelächter]
die Moderation zu übernehmen
Verhandlungen oder
Verhandlungen bei denen Russland von
vornherein signalisiert wird an den
Sanktionen wird sich nichts ändern
bitte an einigen nicht
es gibt wieder Gummibärchen aus Bonn für
russische Supermärkte
im Bereich sozusagen von Warenverkehr
und sowas Gummibärchen aus Bonn
also das ist ja dann kein kein
verhandlungsantrag
der verhandlungsanwalt wäre dass du
Sanktion zurück nimmst
sind die anderen aber wenn ja also ich
ich nehme den Ball jetzt mal und laufen
bisschen weiter ins Feld rein ähm und
würde auch einfach sagen um dieses mit
diesem Security compact abzuschließen da
steht natürlich auch noch andere Punkte
drin wieder Aufbauhilfe für die Ukraine
auch darüber wurde ja schon sehr viel
gesprochen
genau und die EU kann übrigens achtung
jetzt glänze ich mit meinem EU wissen
die kann Artikel 22 ziehen und kann die
Ukraine zu einem strategischen Interesse
deklarieren musstest du das gerade hallo
[Gelächter]
und das ist nämlich der Stichwort die
Frage ist doch
was passiert dann wenn ihr das zu einem
strategischen Weise auch nicht wie bei
der EU
die die EU ich habe den Artikel hier
sogar angeguckt im Zoo macht der Mann
aus seiner Talkshow
in aller Regel reicht das jedenfalls ich
habe ich habe mir den Artikel
tatsächlich angeguckt im Zug und da
steht drin ja wenn die EU will und die
Kommission kann das vorschlagen und so
dann kann die kann die irgendwas zu
einem strategischen Interesse quasi
erklären und dachte ich und dann
aber ich weiß auch nicht ob das je
gemacht wurde ja aber muss
heike hat einen schlechten eu-abend
heute jedenfalls jetzt nehme ich quasi
einfach diesen Punkt und sagst klingt
alles gut aber sind wir mal ganz ehrlich
aus einer ukrainischen Perspektive
könnte man doch sagen kinders Budapester
memorant um 2.0 wir lassen uns Dich noch
nicht noch mal so verladen so und
deswegen würde ich jetzt mal in quasi
aufsteigender Form eskalieren und sagen
erstens EU-Mitgliedschaft ist klar also
sozusagen der Moment klar
dann kommt
ja 42.7 so darauf
mal 42 7 dass die Beistand
Verpflichtungen im Innen wollte nämlich
einmal aufregen lassen würde du kannst
auch mal zum Punkt kommen die Ukraine
will also natürlich diese
EU-Mitgliedschaft und dieser Prozess ist
angestoßen und wenn die Ukraine eine
EU-Mitglied wäre hätte sie nach 42.7
eben sozusagen Beistand
garantiens EU NATO ja die Ukraine will
natürlich in die NATO würde die NATO
eine geteilte Ukraine aufnehmen nein
nein nein die Ukraine glaube ich nicht
kommt kommt nicht in die Natur Punkt was
macht die Ukraine dann unter Umständen
sie beschafft sich nur klärwaffen
ja klar das ist ein logischer Schritt
logisch und das sind auch Dinge die man
jetzt schon mal nachdenken muss ich bin
ja bekanntlich derjenige der seit ja den
24 Februar 2022 den Leuten versucht zu
erklären diese Nuklearwaffen die in der
Ukraine waren diese sowjetischen hätte
die Ukraine nicht benutzen dürfen
trotzdem das narrativ ist nicht tot zu
kriegen muss sondern ukrainischen
Perspektive würde ich vielleicht auch
sagen na ja gut wenn man den Dingern
lang genug rumgeschraubt hätten wäre es
vielleicht schon irgendwie gegangen und
hätten wir sie vielleicht doch viel
lieber mal behalten vielleicht ist es
ein riesiger Anreiz dafür dass er von
denen auch so gesagt worden das hat ja
irgendwann mal der Verteidigungsmittel
deswegen bringe ich den Punkt vielleicht
stehen wir irgendwann in einem Jahr in
einem halben Jahr ja oder nein wir
hoffen alle dass möglichst bald die
Waffen schweigen aber verstehen wir
irgendwann vorne Punkt wo die Ukraine
sagt so ja nicht verbreitungsregim ist
und Pumpe hat uns nichts genutzt
wir wollen jetzt nur klar machen
ja aber die würden doch damit so ihre
ganzen westlichen Verbündeten vor dem
kopfstoßen dass ich mir denke was es
gibt doch nichts was für die Ukraine
aktuell wertvoller ist als die
Unterstützung aus dem Westen und dann so
ein Scheiß wertvoller ist
deswegen hat Israel auch welche
deswegen ist es halt auch ja israel will
beides hat auch keine auch genau darf
ich mal sagen
was nicht auszuschließen ist theoretisch
sage ich jetzt mal ja aber ansonsten
müssen sie am Park ist ja nur Nordkorea
ran und dann sind sozusagen im
chinesischen also warum
Ukraine war sozusagen
nukleartechnologisch mit Russland in der
Sowjetunion die Ukraine waren ganz
wesentlicher Kern ähm sozusagen der das
nuklear technologischen und der
Produktion das ist jetzt auch nicht so
ewig her und wie viel ist davon noch
übrig sozusagen
wie nennt sich dass sie Infrastruktur
nicht mehr sie haben Material
Entschuldigung mit dem größten
Atomkraftwerk Europas hast du schwer
also gewisses
materialischen Punkt machen ich finde
diese ganze Debatte um tatsächliche
beistandsklauseln also EU 42 7 wie schön
dass wir immer wieder erwähnen oder auch
Artikel nato-artikel 5 ich bin überhaupt
nicht überzeugt davon dass das der
Ukraine so krass viel bringt was ich
damit meine ist wir sehen doch gerade
dass die Ukraine volle Unterstützung vom
Westen hat was genau kriegt sie denn
nein
sehr klar definierte Grenzen ja und das
ist aber auch nicht überschreiten wollen
ja aber deswegen sozusagen ist ist das
der Unterschied zu einer
Sicherheitsgarantie das heißt nicht dass
ich sozusagen automatisch greift aber
sozusagen die geht weiter wir haben eine
ganz klare Linie gezogen die heißt wir
liefern da alles nicht alles aber wir
liefern da sehr viel hin aber wir werden
uns nicht da aktiv einbringen was ich
meine ist keine Frage wer die Ukraine
vor dem 24 Februar 2022 oder noch vor 20
14 NATO Mitglied gewesen dieser Krieg
hätte so nicht stattgefunden das finde
ich absolut klar aber jetzt ist hat doch
eigentlich
der besten sehr klare
Message gesendet dass man die Ukraine
unterstützt und dass man eben so eine
Invasion durch Russland nicht akzeptiert
und ich denke mir halt wenn jetzt dieser
Krieg beendet wird es gibt Grenzen
ich bin noch nicht so richtig davon
überzeugt dass die
wir lassen der russischen also ich bin
ja die erste die sagt 42.7 ist es ist
wichtig und so weiter aber ich sehe
irgendwie nicht dass diese Grenzen in
einem Szenario in der die Ukraine
Mitglied der EU ist fallen
wisst ihr was ich meine also so ich bin
ich bin einfach nicht davon überzeugt
dass dann die Unterstützung
weitergeht und ich finde jetzt
eigentlich ist die ist die messehoe 7
gibt's nicht viel Unterstützung
Artikel 5 Beileids Telegramm und oder
oder
einmal angerufen worden ja in Frankreich
hat dazu geführt die Bundeswehr ist in
Mali ja aber bei der bei der un-seite
und nicht bei der französischen Seite ja
da siehst du schon die Grenzen ja wer
ist dabei Punkt ja sagst halt nicht so
laut weil wenn in Kiew sitzen vielleicht
Leute die ist auch alles zu wissen und
sich überlegen und sagen ja auf all
diese Dinge ist halt kein Verlass wir
haben es einmal versucht und das ist das
Ergebnis
gewesen die Frage Artikel 5 Amerikaner
ist darauf verlassen oder nicht und dann
hat man ja Jahrzehnte lang rumgefrickelt
um das sozusagen enger zu machen mit
Blick dass die Amerikaner dann doch
involviert werden das hast Du immer als
Problem aber ich gebe dir ja recht
die Entwicklung könnte auch so laufen
dass sozusagen man wie nennt sich
hatching best of Deutsch seine Wetten
wie beim Roulette platziert also auf
schwarz und auf Rot setzt ja und
trotzdem parallel versucht Nuklearwaffen
zu bekommen klar und ich glaube einfach
um den auf den Ausgangspunkt
zurückzukommen vieles wird dann schon
davon abhängen wie in Anführungszeichen
der Krieg ausgeht ja also wie dieser
irgendwie von uns nicht antizipierbare
Endzustand dann ist und in welchen
Zustand Russland ist mit natürlichem
massiven Einfluss darauf haben wie in
kieft dann die Gedanken Prozesse sind
und was man bereit ist oder was man dann
anstrebt ja
jetzt haben
wir ein gewisses Schweigen der
Ratlosigkeit
weiß ich gar nicht ob das ratlos war ich
finde wir haben das sehr sehr gut
durchdiskutiert
leider war der Punkt ist natürlich Punkt
nein der mir sozusagen mehr Sorgen macht
weil über den ich geredet wird
wie organisieren wir die Sicherheit all
jener Länder die in dieser Twilight Zone
sind und die sozusagen schneller von den
Russen eingenommen werden können als wir
Pieps sagen können also Georgien
Georgien so das sind ja sozusagen die
nächsten potenziellen Kandidaten für
russische Aggression egal wie dieser
Krieg ausgeht und wenn die russischen
anfangen Bambule zu machen sind die
schneller durch Moldawien als die NATO
auch nur irgendeine mit zeichnungswelle
organisieren kann so und da stell ich
mir die Frage wie organisieren wir deren
Sicherheit weil die sind zu schwach um
das selber machen zu können
ja sie werden nicht Mitglieder der NATO
oder der EU werden auf abziehbare Zeit
also der NATO sowieso nicht aber auch
nicht der EU auf absehbare Zeit und die
liegen da und im Prinzip sozusagen sind
die ja in Neukölln würde man sagen du
opfer
und ja dann will ich euch fragen ob ihr
eine Idee dazu habt
nächstes Thema ja
du hast auch keine
Ahnung
wo man sagt man hat überall eine
amerikanische Garnison
bitte das beißt sich mit dem Punkt dass
die Amerikaner das nicht machen sollen
die Amerikaner wollen dauerhaft nicht in
dieser starke und Präsenz in Europa
bleiben ja was wir beim Baltikum zum
Beispiel tun ja aber lies die neue
national security Strategie Europa muss
mehr für seine Sicherheit tun aber das
Schreiben doch schon seit so seitdem ich
denken kann aber unsere Diskussion
signalisiert ja dass wir weit über das
aktuelle hinaus uns über diese Dinge
massiv Gedanken machen und zwar jetzt
jetzt
Abstimmungsprozesse brauchen das muss
wir müssen darüber streiten was das
richtige ist und dann müssen wir ja dann
tut dass man Geld in die Hand nehmen
muss an gewissen Punkt sowieso und
vermutlich auch europäisch Dinge neu
organisieren muss ja weil wenn zum
Beispiel so ist angenommen es ist der
schlimmste Möglichkeit ein Ja und davon
sollte man in aller Regel heutzutage
ausgehen
dieses der Konflikt frisst sich fest und
es sieht sozusagen es ist sozusagen
Szenario 3 ja also weder Ukraine gewinnt
was auch immer das bedeutet und Russland
gewinnt auch nicht sondern wir haben
dieses geteilte Land und wir haben
permanent im Prinzip auch auf einem
niedrigen intensitätsniveau weiterhin
Konflikt in Washington ist Gaga angesagt
ja und wir müssen es selber organisieren
also wie viel Zeit wollen wir uns denn
lassen in Europa diese Sachen
mal so langsam aufs Gleis zu setzen das
ist das ist das im Grunde sozusagen
Meter mäßig was man aus diesem Thema
außer diese Diskussion mitnehmen muss
und die Frage ist wer macht das
Europa halt eigentlich ich denke
Immanuel
[Gelächter]
letztendlich dann doch immer wieder
darauf zurückkommen und dann brauchen
wir dieses Jahr Sicherheitsgarantie von
den Amis oder eben von der NATO und das
ist ja letztendlich auch vor allen
Dingen vor einigen Jahren
setzt sich hin und sagt wir
strukturieren das eigentlich sollte das
tatsächlich die EU sein und ich meine
wirklich die EU im Sinne von Brüssel EU
weil wir reden doch schon ich weiß gar
nicht wie viel Jahre über die
geopolitische EU wir haben irgendwie
Außenbeauftragte wir haben
Kommissionspräsidenten und so weiter
eigentlich wäre das der Moment für die
Europäische Union ich sehe es noch nicht
wirklich also
Papier fehlen ganz Sinn die das wirklich
Regeln unter anderem auch deswegen
interessanterweise ja weil die EU ja
auch nicht ernst genommen wird von
Russland von China wir bringen auch
nicht aber das ist ein anderes Thema das
haben wir jetzt gerade gesehen aber aber
von Russland also es ich finde es ich
finde es ja wahnsinnig traurig als
jemand die immer wieder die Lanze bricht
für europäische Souveränität und
Autonomie und so weiter das ist immer
wieder darauf hinausläuft dass wir sagen
wir brauchen aber doch die Amerikaner
mit ihrer ganzen Macht dahinter nicht
nur jetzt tatsächlich für die
Sicherheitsgarantie und Boots ohne
ground sondern auch einfach als
irgendwie Akteur und und
moderierendes Element aber die EU ist
soweit noch nicht und innerhalb Europas
Frankreich ist es nicht
Deutschland will ja nicht und kann auch
nicht nur richtig und wer soll da noch
so sein die Briten die sind nicht mehr
die sind gerade
der Kontinent ist immer noch nicht
abgedriftet
ja Europa gesagt die dritten haben ja
auch wahnsinnig Macht und Einfluss
tatsächlich verloren also durch die
Kombination aus brexit und wieder gerade
die die generelle politische Situation
läuft wie die Wirtschaft läuft also die
die haben auch einfach nicht mehr das
die gravitas habe ich mal sagen die die
USA sollen die Verhandlung organisieren
wollen es vielleicht aber nicht unter
Trump und garantieren sollst dann Europa
was es nicht kann ist das dann so die
bottom-line
okay das ist ein optimistisches Fazit
wäre
wie man so kennt wollen wir ich habe
mich nur gefragt wollen wir noch mal
ganz kurz aufdröseln warum NATO
Mitgliedschaft für die Ukraine
eigentlich so ein bisschen erscheinen
ist aber ich finde es mehrmals so rein
geworfen du hast gesagt
sowieso nicht aber ich finde das wichtig
denn wir reden ja wahnsinnig viel über
die NATO-Mitgliedschaft und die Ukraine
hat es in ihrer in ihrer Verfassung
stehen und will das und ist klar aber es
gibt doch also ich für mich gibt es zwei
Elemente zum einen es wird doch
wahrscheinlich praktisch nicht
funktionieren weil die NATO das gar
nicht will
ja sagen und die andere Frage ist für
mich auch so ein bisschen macht das denn
überhaupt Sinn also wie wie wie viel
Mehrwert gibt das wirklich und wie viel
Nachteile weil wenn ich mal so durch
dekliniere für die NATO jedes neue
Mitglied soll die Sicherheit der
nato-allianz erhöhen sorry also das
Argument kann man glaube ich werde
Ukraine nicht machen auch wenn die jetzt
extrem
entschuldigung
ich entschuldigen aber also ich würde
jetzt nicht ich finde das Argument zu
machen Ukraine erhöht die Sicherheit der
NATO ist schon mal schwierig für
Russland ist das natürlich absolut rotes
Tuch das mag uns vielleicht nicht
interessieren oder man sagt immer sagen
wie bei wie bei Finnland ja gut das habt
ihr euch selber eingebrockt aber es ist
zumindest noch ein weiteres Problem
irgendwie in dem Verhältnis zu Russland
und wie gesagt für die für die Ukraine
ich ich bin einfach irgendwie nicht so
richtig davon überzeugt dass in der
aktuellen Situation wo ja der Westen
wirklich signalisiert hat dass er die
Ukraine unterstützt dass du diese diese
Mitgliedschaft
kurzfristig da so ein so einen großen
Einfluss hat ich verstehe ich verstehe
was ihr sagt aber also dass das hätte
vor ein paar Jahren wirklich einen
Unterschied gemacht jetzt glaube ich hat
der Westen auch wirklich gezeigt wir
lassen es nicht zulassen dass das
Russland da einmarschiert und daher also
ich ich finde es einfach nicht so
richtig
überzeugend also es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht passieren aber ich bin auch nicht
so richtig davon überzeugt dass es so so
erstrebenswert ist ähm dass die dass die
Ukraine der Natur
ich glaube das lassen wir mal so stehen
weil das ist jetzt wirklich sehr
spekulativ spekulieren nee hat Frank
gesagt aber an der Stelle hätte ich
würde gerne noch kurz auf einen anderen
Punkte über den wir auch auf jeden Fall
reden müssen
nämlich nicht nur
was ist wenn die Waffen schweigen
sondern die aktuelle Debatte die wir ja
schon haben über es muss Verhandlungen
geben
es muss Verhandlung jetzt geben oder als
extreme Forderungen keine
Waffenlieferung nur Verhandlungen und
zwar sofort wir haben inzwischen eine
Debatte ich glaube es ist klar geworden
wie kompliziert dieser ganze Prozess
wird selbst wenn die Waffen schweigen
aber
wie gehen wir eigentlich jetzt aktuell
mit der Debatte um die eigentlich ja
eher darauf hinausläuft schickt keine
Waffen mehr und dann Schluss und dann
ist Frieden
ja ich meine jetzt anknüpfend kann man
sich ja vorstellen wir haben ja ohnehin
schon relativ aufgeheizten Diskurs und
so darüber zu reden dass die Ukraine
möglicherweise in die NATO kommen sollte
selbst wenn wir das hier nicht
sonderlich
gangbar halten
würde ja dann auch schon gleich wieder
den Trigger darstellen für glaube ich
viele Menschen die sagen ja gut aber das
wäre dann doch noch mehr eine
Provokation für Russland
und deswegen wollen wir tatsächlich noch
ein paar Minuten auch darauf aufwenden
darüber zu reflektieren
wie wir über solche Dinge diskutieren
und wie wir über solche Sachen auch
streiten ja also wenn es so ist dass wir
die europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur
gemeinsam als Europäerinnen und Europäer
neu gestalten wollen müssen wir
irgendwie ein Modus finden indem man das
halbwegs produktiv hinbekommt und wir
vier wir sind jetzt ein bisschen auf der
Metaebene wir vier haben
und wir vier hatten uns im Vorfeld eben
auch überlegt dass es sinnvoll sein
könnte darüber mal ein paar Worte zu
verlieren und sozusagen um als
Einstimmung lese ich jetzt mal etwas
länger
auf eine E-Mail vor die wir bekommen
haben
von dem Hörer ich habe natürlich gefragt
ob ich das darf ich darf das natürlich
die ist lang wie sie sehen
einen längeren Teil vor und es lohnt
sich
Zitat
als jemand der im Studium beigebracht
bekam sich nicht in die schwachen Seiten
einer Argumentation sondern aus den
Motiven Reflexivität und lernen sich
immer nur in den stärksten Punkt der
Position zu versenken graut es mir vor
den derzeitigen Diskussionen zum
ukrainekrieg ziemlich ich musste
beispielsweise feststellen dass man auch
als entschiedener Unterstützer der
Ukraine und Befürworter von
Waffenlieferung sofort als
querfrontlerwurbler Putin ab 40 Leonardo
und so weiter diskreditiert wird wenn
man beispielsweise auf Diskurse in
Afrika und Lateinamerika verweist und
vor moralische hybriswahnt zu vergessen
woher diese kritischen Blicke auf
westliche Politiken kommen ich arbeite
in einem Umfeld mit hohem Anteil an
migrantischen Kolleginnen und habe dort
festgestellt dass dort sehr ähnliche
Betrachtung und Vergleiche angestellt
werden wie in Afrika und Lateinamerika
auch wurde mir von diesen vielfach
berichtet wie Diskussionen zum Krieg
schnell eskalieren und Beziehungen über
solche Streitigkeiten abbrechen gerade
weil in Deutschland MigrantInnen
Angestellten lieber unter sich bleiben
und nur unter ihnen vertrauten
bio-deutschen überhaupt Gedanken äußern
die nicht zum deutschen Mainstream
gehören finde ich das bedenklich so
entstehen Echokammern die eine kritische
Öffentlichkeit beschädigen vor diesem
Hintergrund möchte ich anregen auch
einmal die Art des Kurses in der
Republik zum Thema in sicherheitshalber
zu machen warum die Gräben so tief sind
warum der Diskurs so polarisiert warum
ein dazwischen so schnell dieser
ruiniert die railt das what aboutism und
der Putin Fee verdächtigt wird dass ein
kritischer Diskurs nicht mehr möglich
ist ich selbst habe vor gut 30 Jahren
bevor ich schließlich doch ausgemustert
wurde total verweigert und saß in
Hammelburg in beuge gehabt selbst dort
wurde ich aber seitens des Kompaniechefs
ernster genommen und respektvoller
behandelt als in der heutigen
politischen Diskussion Zitat Ende
Beugehaft besser als die heutige
politische Geschichte
und also wir haben ja die Diskussion
begonnen damit zu sagen uns eint ja alle
das Ziel niemand im Raum niemand in
Deutschland niemand in Europa der nicht
insbesondere in der Ukraine natürlich
der nicht Frieden will allein die
Diskussion des letzten Jahres entzündete
sich daran dass wir uns über den Weg zum
Frieden oder die Mittel nicht einig sind
direkt abgesprochen wird das ist ja
interessanter also jedem der irgendwie
jetzt zum Beispiel Argument für
Waffenlieferung mal gemacht hat wurde
doch sicher also ihr wahrscheinlich alle
schon mal angegangen nach dem Motto du
stehst ja für Krieg und ich für Frieden
also selbst diese
selbst diese dieses Ziel dieses
gemeinsame Ziel natürlich wollen wir
alle letztendlich Frieden in der Ukraine
selbst das wird ja teilweise einem einem
abgesprochen okay aber das okay okay ähm
das ist immer sozusagen dann unterstellt
man auch jemanden wirklich die nächste
Motive also ich würde sagen
da sind wir beim Problem in gewissen
sind aber dass wir eben
Waffenlieferungen natürlich nicht
irgendwie geil sondern das eben als die
notwendige Vorbedingung dafür sehen dass
man irgendwann tatsächlich hoffentlich
verhandeln kann und mit Appellen alleine
wir zum Frieden nicht kommen das ist
eben sozusagen irgendwie die Krux an
dieser ganzen Debatte aber ich habe mir
jetzt zum Beispiel die Arbeit gemacht
und habe in dieser Appelle noch mal
reingeguckt und ja also ich finde da
natürlich schon viele Sätze die ich so
einfach unterschreiben würde schon
einzelne dass man sagt russischen
Angriffskrieg stoppen ja weg zu
Verhandlungen finden ja waffenschilder
erreichen ja will ich alles ja ich habe
dann Kritik und würde sagen
ich finde die ignoriert die Ukraine zu
sehr warum Gerichten sich die Appelle
irgendwie immer
sozusagen Richtung Berlin oder
Washington und nie nach Moskau und so
aber dass wir noch mal dass uns das Ziel
eint ist klar und die Lehre aus der
Pandemie ist dass wir es nicht so weit
kommen lassen dürfen dass wir am Ende
zwei unversöhnliche Lager haben die sich
im Prinzip nicht mal mehr darüber einig
sind was eigentlich die Realität ist
aber die haben wir doch die aber der
Punkt ist und da sprichst du gerade an
es geht ja diese Polarisierung ist jetzt
bei der Ukraine da aber es geht nicht um
die Ukraine und das ist glaube ich das
Hauptproblem diese Polarisierung fing
keine Ahnung wann an aber ich würde sie
jetzt erstmal datieren bei 2015/2016 so
und dann geht die nahtlos weiter zu
Corona und dann geht die jetzt so
Ukraine und keine Ahnung in zwei Jahren
kommt das nächste Thema und sozusagen es
wird genauso wieder sein ja ich glaube
und das ist das Problem also ich rede
jetzt nur von der deutschen Debatte ne
es gibt so eine keine Ahnung prozentual
10 15% in der Bevölkerung sehr aktiv auf
Social Media
die a massiv beeinflussbar ist durch
Desinformationskampagnen und B sozusagen
sich die Themen sucht wo sie ihre
generelle Kritik an diesen System
Deutschland und an diesen ganzen
Schergen und am öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und so weiter aufmachen kann
das heißt die dominieren die Diskussion
und deswegen ich würde ja auch
bestreiten dass wir alle an dem gleichen
Ziel arbeiten ich glaube das ganz ganz
viele Figuren die die öffentliche
Diskussion bestimmen und die sozusagen
die Diskussion auf Social Media
antreiben das ein feuchten Kehricht
interessieren na ja gut aber
Social Media also Öffentlichkeit
na ja aber das ist schon ein Unterschied
also dieses ganze toxische gehabt habe
auf Twitter so du Kriegstreiber und
whatever ich glaube bei dir gab es ein
paar Tweets dazu
gesehen
das meine ich noch nicht mal sondern die
Debatte insgesamt
wird ja zunehmend vergiftet und ich habe
auch ein Problem mit der Aussage wir
wollen eigentlich alle in die gleiche
Richtung wenn gesagt wird aber
Waffenlieferung gehen gar nicht
weil Waffenlieferung ist kein Weg zum
Frieden und wer Waffenlieferung will
will kein Frieden
das kommt ja auch sehr stark ich mache
mal ich mache mal einen Unterschied und
da würde ich ihn festmachen wir sind
doch jetzt noch bei dem fernsehteil ne
da muss ich mich sprachlich irgendwie
überweisen nicht mehr lange Margot
Käßmann
hat eine für mich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbare aber sehr konstante
Position egal zu welchem Thema das fing
bei
afghanistaner auf kann ich alles nicht
nachvollziehen aber das ist eine Figur
die sehr Konstantin ihre Argumentation
ist was zurückzuführen ist auf ein
völlig verstrahlten Pazifismus fein bei
mir Moment Stopp
es gibt andere Figuren die in anderen
Situationen überhaupt gar kein Problem
mit Waffenlieferungen haben die haben in
dieser spezifischen Situation Problem
mit Waffenlieferung weil das Russland
geht und da fängt mein Problem an
verstehst du also ich kann ich kann mit
einer Figur wie Margot Käßmann
sicherlich diskutieren weil ich
zumindestens akzeptiere dass die
konstant ist in ihrem Denken ja aber mit
den anderen Figuren weiß ich die haben
eine Agenda aber und da ist die
Diskussionsfähigkeit nicht mehr da das
ist das Problem online wie offline
müsste das Ideal natürlich sein die
werden wir auch nicht immer gerecht
vorkommen klar dass man eben nicht Strom
wenn er abbrennt sondern quasi für die
Gegenseite Stahl Männer baut ja sich
nehmen was die Frau Käßmann z.B sagt und
versucht es so stark zu machen wie es
nur irgendwie geht und dann gucke ich ob
ich Argumente habe wie man den
entgegenhalten kann und ich glaube das
Problem ist oft und die sozialen Medien
sind da im Prinzip nur der der
Durchlauferhitzer der das eben sozusagen
schneller und heißer macht das solche
Sachen wie Frieden bei anderen
sollen wir mal für den Diskurs
relevanten Personen nur eine Schiffe
sind die diese Echo Kammer bedient ja
und ich habe damit aber muss ich auch
sagen ein Problem auf beiden Seiten also
man muss nämlich sozusagen oder beide
Seiten ist schwierig das machen wir
quasi schon so ein zwei Lager Denken auf
aber ich sehe auch vielen Seiten mit
Blick darauf ein Problem ich will jetzt
sozusagen
quasi diese Praxis mal anwenden und
sagen nachdem ich hier eine relativ
harte Kante gefahren habe und gesagt hat
Containment und wer weiß
und sagen es gibt natürlich viele gute
Dinge die wie immer man das jetzt nennen
will die Friedensbewegung oder so in
Deutschland
Jahre und jahrzehntelang hoch gehalten
hat die garantiert auch immer noch ihren
Weg Wert haben in einer zukünftigen
Europa und einer neuen
Sicherheitsarchitektur ich meine dass
wir Rüstungskontrolle irgendwie mit
Russland machen müssen um irgendwie
Risiken zu minimieren ist schon klar
aber keine Ahnung sie will
gesellschaftliche Austausch
wissenschaftlicher Austausch ja
vielleicht sind das auch Dinge die man
wieder machen muss das heißt gezielt
suchen auch ob die Gegenseite nicht auch
gute Argumente hat die man
unterschreiben würde dafür bin ich und
ich sag noch mal weil wir jetzt über
witziges so differenziert ist doch die
Diskussion nicht nee aber was will dass
sie so differenziert ist das ist ja mein
Punkt ja gut weil jetzt von der
Friedensbewegung redest was du alles
gesagt hast ist sozusagen kommt aus der
Friedensforschung die nichts mit der
Friedensbewegung zu tun hat ist ganz
wichtig weil die Friedensbewegung was
anderes ist aber zahlt euch im Büro
sonst oder was ja das ist
mit dem Büros an der Uni ist schwierig
aber ich sage das jetzt nur noch mal
damit ich mich wirklich auch garantiert
unbeliebt gemacht habe mich störe mich
stören auch auf andere Seite im Prinzip
diese extrem zugespitzten Positionen die
bei jedem irgendwie der sagt ja aber wer
Frieden nicht auch eine Option sofort
sozusagen oben raus sind und ähm und und
ja wie soll man sagen am liebsten ich
kriege Zuschriften Moment Leute
schreiben sie würden am liebsten Moskau
bombardieren und das ist einfach zu
Match ja also die Leute müssen sich
einfach mal abkühlen in dieser Debatte
weil wir sonst eben genauso diese
differenzierten Diskussion nie wieder
zurück finden und wir haben dann genau
dieselbe Misere wie mit der Pandemie
dass wir Teams haben den Hashtags und
dann ist man halt teamleiterbach oder
irgend so ein Nonnen sind und was hat
uns gebracht in der Pandemie gar nichts
wir können jetzt inzwischen in der
Rückschau nicht mal mehr vernünftig
leeren draußen ziehen wie die eigentlich
war und ob wir irgendwas richtig oder
falsch gemacht haben weil wir uns quasi
darüber streiten was Realität war die
letzten drei Jahre und so auf diese
Kurve
ja manchmal hat man fast den Eindruck
ich brennen für meine Themen
[Applaus]
aber diesen diesen dieses Element mit
den Teams das finde ich auch ganz
problematisch ich habe immer mehr den
Eindruck je länger dieser Krieg geht
desto mehr sortieren sich auch Menschen
selber in eben solche solche Schubladen
ein wie du sagst dann hat man auch so so
buzwörter und Hashtags und wer quasi
nicht hundert Prozent für das Team ist
der ist irgendwie dagegen und das ist
natürlich total problematisch überhaupt
nicht zielführend ich denke das ist zum
einen soziales Mediums Phänomen mag sein
ich meine von selbst erledigen auch
wieder warten ich glaube du hast ja ganz
am Anfang gefragt warum sind diese
Gräben so tief ich meine man muss
natürlich erstmal noch anerkennen und
das war im übrigen auch bei der Pandemie
so es geht ja hier schon um Leben und
Tod also es ist ja jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie
sowas wo man sagen kann ja gut und
einigen uns irgendwie Mütter also es
geht ja wirklich um was und es geht um
foltern es geht um Leid und all sowas
insofern das ist dann sehr extreme
Positionen gibt und dass man da auch
vielleicht schnell gegensätzige
Positionen nicht anerkennt oder
diskreditiert dass das kann ich zum
gewissen gerade zumindest menschlich
nachvollziehen das ist jetzt nicht gut
für die Debatte aber ich kannst du mir
menschlich nachvollziehen ich ein
anderes Element was mir auch immer
wieder begegnet ist es gibt so ein
Problem zwischen den Leuten die sich
sehr mit diesem Thema beschäftigen ob
sie jetzt professionelles oder in der
Freizeit also Leute die da sehr drin
sind und Leute die das mehr soeben in
den Medien verfolgen das begegnet mir
immer wieder so auch z.B in den sozialen
Medien weil weil weil so Sachen dann von
außen herangetragen werden da denke ich
das haben wir doch schon dreimal
abgefrühstückt und wenn das immer wieder
kommt dann finde ich antwortet man auch
irgendwie immer kürzer und klarer und
auch in die zugespitzter weil man denkt
so oh das kann ich jetzt nicht noch mal
nicht noch mal machen und ich glaube da
ist auch so eine Gefahr dass das die
Diskussion auch so schwierig macht dass
man dann auch selber teilweise in der
extremere Position reingetrieben wird
weil man den Eindruck hat so
ist das jetzt ist das jetzt ernsthafter
irgendwie Einwand oder willst du
irgendwie nur noch mal die Debatte
aufräumen damit da nichts bei rumkommt
das ist einfach mir persönlich ein
bisschen ich will noch einen Punkt
machen ganz kurz weil wir nähern uns
genau
ich finde es völlig legitim und das
kommt von mir ich bin nicht sehr bekannt
dafür dass man in gewissen Situationen
sozusagen auch ein emotionalen Moment
hat
also wenn mir irgendwo einmal
ich bin normalerweise relativ Flatline
aber wenn wir irgendjemand um die Ecke
kommt und zum Beispiel Vergewaltigung
relativiert dann finde ich das völlig
legitim dass man daraus der Haut fährt
und dass man da auch unverschämt wird
also wir müssen jetzt nicht immer so tun
als ob man sozusagen das Gegenüber immer
mit Samthandschuhen anpacken muss egal
was für ein Argument davon ist kein
Podcast mit dir machen wenn
wir müssen auch nicht jemanden
Stuhlkreis machen aber wie wir z.B die
Frage ist natürlich jetzt zum Abschluss
kommen wir da raus nein
doch wenn wir mehr solche
Diskussionen führen wie wir sie zum
Beispiel jetzt mit unserem Publikum
bestimmt führen werden dann können wir
zumindest diesen
Hashtag Team Bildungs- Nonsens eine
vernünftige Diskussion und ein
zivilisierten Austausch entgegensetzen
wie weit ist das bringt weiß ich nicht
wir versuchen quasi in zum gewissen Grad
in Beitrag dazu zu leisten mit all den
Schwächen die wir übrigens selber haben
das war das Ding ne wenn ich überhaupt
nicht hinstellen sondern wir machen das
irgendwie immer richtig über alle so
werden wie wir aber zumindest eben in
dieser Diskussion ist ist der versucht
mit den Menschen hier im Saal und das
hoffe ich mir macht einen Klick zu
kleinen Beitrag wir predigen mir ohnehin
zu den Gläubigen es gibt in Deutschland
eine Gruppe von Menschen ich kann sie
nicht beziffern prozentual die sozusagen
nicht mehr erreichbar sind und die
werden bei jedem Thema genau die
gleiche stellen aber von denen muss man
sich ja quasi auch nicht in dieser
relativieren lassen die ist ja relativ
fix ja ich glaube das Thema an also
sozusagen
erweitert naja aber das sind die die von
Virologe umgeschult haben auf Putin
verstehe ja aber das sind auch die die
sozusagen morgen schon mal Trommeln und
einen Sonnengott anbeten die sich
plötzlich mit rechtsextreme auf der
Straße fahren die finden sich jetzt auch
wieder und beim nächsten Thema kommt
vielleicht noch eine andere Gruppe dazu
die besonders betroffen ist also wir
haben sozusagen einen gew issen Kreis an
Menschen der nicht mehr mit mit der sich
nicht an Debatten beteiligen will und
nicht in dem es nicht darum geht um das
beste Argument zu bringen sondern den
geht es um eine grundsätzliche
Opposition gegen dieses Land in dem wir
leben und die kriegen wir nicht erreicht
unsere optimistischen Schlussworte
verabschieden sollten wir uns vielleicht
netterweise schon wir verabschieden uns
jetzt von den Fernsehzuschauern sagen
vielen Dank dass Sie dabei geblieben
sind es gibt uns im Podcast also in
diesem Internet ins Audio zum Nachhören
regelmäßig alle drei Wochen und
danke schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]